Harry did them I think from her parents
or something like that like it's all
it's deeply twisted and warped and of
course it was it now of course we can
objectively look at it and go slavery
was wrong and you shouldn't of course
but they all were doing things in their
time that you the world doesn't
magically become what you want it to be
just because you exist and think
something and and the more that we start
thinking that the more will eventually
come after Obama for running against gay
marriage the first time and and all of
these things there is something that we
think you love meat right you love elk
and all this other stuff guess what one
day if this craziness keeps going they
will look back when you're a grandfather
and they'll be like they ate meat
because we're at that point we'll be
eating you know artificially produced
whatever and they'll they'll literally
watch videos of you chomping on you know
some ribs and go see what a savage he
was so that's why you have to just be
aware of what your time is I'm in this
world yeah they're doing it right now
exactly yeah um did you ever see the
video of Obama talking about illegal
immigration it's incredible it's it's
really amazing it's when he was a
senator and downing for president the
first time and he is more like he's
stricter than in that trunk
yes I mean it's a fascinating thing
because no one brings that up and no one
called him braces then but I guess we're
dealing with a long time ago you know
it's well I mean there's a couple of
things it was it was it 2011 he was
doing that he was a senator so it was
probably around 2010 2011 something like
that I mean look there's a lot of things
there right he mean he's black number
one so it's like they're not gonna call
him racist it doesn't it creates a thing
where they can't compute what does that
actually mean he was saying the things
that people wanted to hear he also
wanted to be elected yeah he wanted to
be elected so they elevated him to a
point that he was God play this listen
to this 2005 2005 yeah this is early on
oh so he's on the need to better secure
the border and to punish employers who
choose to hire illegal immigrants you
know we are a generous and welcoming
people here in the United States but
those who enter the country illegally
and those who employ them disrespect the
rule of law and they are showing
disregard for those who are
following the law we simply cannot allow
people to pour into the United States
undetected undocumented unchecked and
circumventing the line of people who are
waiting patiently diligently and
lawfully to become immigrants in this
country so that's why we need to start
by giving agencies charged with border
security new technology new facilities
and more people to stop the process and
deport illegal immigrants
having said that securing the borders
alone does not solve immigration
management we're going to have to better
manage legal immigration in order to end
illegal immigration
senators McCain and Kennedy point us in
the right direction on that point right
now we've got millions of illegal
immigrants who live and work here
without knowing their identity or
background that's part of the reason
that we need a guest worker program to
replace the flood of illegals with a
regulated stream of legals who enter the
United States after checks and with
access to labor rights part of the
reason that illegal immigration is so
damaging is that it ends up creating a
pool of workers with depressed wages and
no rights and that's not something that
we find acceptable it's crazy dude
American employers also need to take
responsibility I mean I just scribble
down like I was doing homework in
seventh grade think about what he said
there we have to secure the border
secure the border trunk yeah secure the
border Wow punish you if you hire if you
hire illegal workers if you if you enter
illegally you're showing disregard for
our laws you we cannot allow illegals to
pour in we can't let them go ahead of
lawful people who are going to enter the
country we need better border security
more more process and deportations we
have to better manage legal immigration
and then he talked about the millions
that are here now which in effect is a
pathway to citizenship which by the way
Trump is basically for at some level so
it's like so what are we really talking
about every time we scream that
everybody is racist
did he just make a wild what sorry I
assume he's talking about Latino people
so is Barack Obama racist against
Latino people well this was when he was
a senator looks like he was elected in
2008 and so he was probably gearing up
to run when he was in 2005 the things
that he was saying he was letting people
know who he is and that he's out there
and starting the ball rolling you know
this is a different time to 2005 was
just a different world and it seems like
it shouldn't be because it was only
thirteen years ago but goddamn is a
different so what does that say then
what does that actually say about the
way things have changed or the cult of
personality around Trump or just sort of
the general derangement of the media
that they can't view these things it's
not just the media I think it's also
people's access to communication the
fact that anyone can voice their opinion
whether it's on Facebook or YouTube or
what-have-you
you know it's it's a different world
Twitter you just you just tweet
instantaneously this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know people should be able to do
whatever they want or whatever you know
whatever you want to say and then a
bunch of people can agree or disagree or
retweet it or you know or screen grab it
because they think that it's damaging to
you and they put I can't believe you
support this piece of [ __ ] and think
that you can wake up on any given
morning find someone you've never heard
of who said something you slightly
disagree with and you can help get them
fired that's a lot there's a lot of
people want to do that to which is
really interesting